décembre 1914
chaque camp espérait une guerre éclair
mais déjà des centaines de milliers de
morts et des hommes épuisés qui
s'enterre dans les tranchées pour y
passer leur premier noël
et soudain l'improbable se produit il a
suffit ici ou là quelques chants qui
s'élève dans la nuit des chants repris
par la tranchée adverse
un premier rang qui s'avance bientôt
suivi par d'autres
non
quand je découvre les fraternisations il
ya 14 ans je suis bouleversée je suis
très émue quoi je me dis ah et aussi ça
ça avance sur un endroit dans un endroit
où normalement on nique où on humeur là
on peut marcher et pas après son face à
face
et voilà donc il ya un moment suspendu
j'essaye de restituer dans le film vous
les rallyes sont voilà qu'est ce qu'on
fait maintenant
comme tout il serait pas félix et d'en
haut c'est nestor l'énoncé des stores
c'est le chant de la ferme delsaux je le
connais mieux petit comment ces gens là
étaient allés aller à la guerre
conditionné dans la haine de l'autre et
d'un seul coup il ya par endroits une
prise de conscience de ces gens
conditionner une prise de conscience de
se dire mais non c'est des gens comme
nous comme moi car des fraternisations
bien eu lieu en plusieurs points du
front ce noël là on a testé par quelques
lettres quelques photos
un livre récent coécrit par quatre
historiens évoquent ses frères de
trancher passer sous silence les terres
ne peut pas mettre pour mettre fin à sa
fonction qui est à la guerre l'ennemi
dont il normal qu il soit contre les
fraternisations cela dit c'est seulement
à l'arrière l'état major et les
militaires de haut rang qui ont vu là un
danger mais dans les tranchées et comme
c'est bien montrer donc une pièce en
carillon les avais j'ai tranché étaient
solidaires de leurs hommes du régiment
n'est pas aisé officiers lutter pour
plus de 11 la réponse de marianne c'est
qu'en fait attendre mais qu'est-ce qui
ces pays sont surpris si je vous dis je
suis senti plus proche des allemands et
ceux qui triment en ronde bosse chez eux
vers l'eau chaude ans lors d'un homard
au seul devant survivants des deux côtés
garderont tant leur coeur le souvenir de
ces heurts
ces gestes naïve peut-être un jour du
mans